so it looks like alex jones is going to
have to pay a huge amount of money to
the parents of the children that were
killed in the sandy hook massacre and
this isn't a case that it wasn't at all
clear that alex jones was going to lose
so how did he snatch defeat from the
jaws of victory well you have to hand it
to him he just achieved something that's
so rare in texas legal circles that one
lawyer called it a unicorn in the law
one lawyer said none of the lawyers i've
spoken with have ever had this happen
but we've never seen such a blatant
disregard for the court's authority the
way we have here so what did jones do in
this lawsuit well first of all there's
four lawsuits that were filed by family
members of three children killed in the
shooting at sandy hook elementary school
in 2012 and despite the verifiable fact
that six adults and 20 children were
murdered by a lone gunman jones has
repeatedly accused sandy hook families
of being crisis actors calling the event
a giant hoax and a false flag operation
and several families of victims have
already sued jones for defamation and
won in 2019 a court ordered jones to pay
court costs and legal fees to parents of
sandy hook victims and in the current
lawsuits jones has steadfastly refused
to turn over relevant evidence to the
plaintiffs despite court orders that
were meant to expedite discovery jones
has declined to provide documents and
evidence but here's the thing about
court orders you really don't have the
right to decline them even if you think
the court is wrong
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a litigator because after three years of
stonewalling a texas judge has finally
seen enough so rather than allowing the
case to go to trial the judge ruled that
jones flagrant bad faith and callous
disregard of the court's orders has
resulted in default judgments that means
that the judge decided the jones and
infowars have legal liability the three
cases will now proceed to trial solely
on one issue how much money jones and
infowars have to pay for defamation and
intentional infliction of emotional
distress so just how did alex jones lose
four lawsuits without proceeding to
trial well let's count the ways and to
understand why the judge issued default
judgments we need to know the basics of
these lawsuits in 2018 the families of
three children filed lawsuits in travis
county texas where jones and his
infowars media system is based the
plaintiffs in these cases contend that
jones false claims motivated people to
harass and intimidate them for example
leonard posner and veronique delarosa
are the parents of six-year-old noah
posner one of jones viewers lucy
richards left voicemails threatening to
kill leonard posner for his alleged role
in the alleged hoax after posner
convinced youtube to remove one of the
jones videos jones then published
posner's home address and showed viewers
information about posner's family
members the posner family has moved
seven times to avoid harassment from
jones viewers the posner delarosa
lawsuit quoted jones as saying that the
school shooting was quote a false flag
meant to give the government an
opportunity to limit second amendment
rights and jones constantly tells his
viewers and listeners that the parents
of the slain children did not have
murdered children they clearly used
actors i mean they even ended up using
photos of kids killed in mass shootings
here in a fake mass shooting in turkey
or pakistan end quote
naturally the parents of children killed
in sandy hook took objection to these
claims neil heslin is the father of
six-year-old jesse lewis after jones
said heslin lied about holding his dead
son in his arms heslin filed two
defamation lawsuits jesse's mother
scarlett also filed a lawsuit against
jones for saying the school shooting was
quote as phony as a three dollar bill
lewis cited numerous statements where
jones and his contributors implied that
the sandy hook parents were not
genuinely grieving for their dead
children by any measure this is
gruesomely offensive stuff but is it
enough to lose a defamation case well
before we go deeper into these cases you
should understand some basic facts about
what we call the discovery process so
let's say that you want to file a civil
lawsuit against someone you race down to
the courthouse fill out the paperwork
what happens next is not trial before
you get your day in court all parties
get an opportunity to get evidence from
each other this is called discovery and
there are several tools that lawyers use
in discovery to gather evidence and some
information disclosures are mandatory
which prevents the other side from
hiding relevant evidence in texas these
required disclosures are covered by the
texas rule of civil procedure 194 and
they include information like the name
and address of all witnesses a list or
copy of all relevant documents and a
description of the legal theories and
defenses each party may use lawyers may
also make requests for production which
each side must answer by producing
documents and things relevant to the
case
and these requests must specify a
reasonable time and date for production
litigants can also ask parties to answer
written questions called interrogatories
and if you've ever wondered what lawyers
are actually doing all day this is
probably it we spend a lot of time
crafting these discovery requests and
responding to them objecting to them and
reviewing answers to them lawyers spend
more time on these activities than they
do inside the courtroom and there also
be things like depositions where
witnesses must give testimony under oath
and throughout this process all parties
negotiate for limitations on discovery
and they try and force the other side to
answer the requests as written there's
back and forth between the parties and
the court but eventually you're going to
have to answer some of this discovery
simply asserting that answering
discovery requests in general is hard
work and cumbersome is generally not
enough to get out of doing those
discovery responses and all this takes
place long before the parties ever get
to trial where you'll have an
adjudication of the case on the merits
in this case the litigants in the
defamation case all made written
discovery requests in 2018 and 2019.
however in response jones and his
collaborators filed motions under the
texas citizens participation act known
as the tcpa to have the lawsuits
dismissed the tcpa is texas's version of
an anti-slap statute which is meant to
be constitutional safeguard protecting
the rights of persons to petition speak
freely associate freely and otherwise
participate in government to the maximum
extent permitted by law and at the same
time protects the rights of persons to
file meritorious lawsuits for
demonstrable injury slaps are shorthand
for strategic lawsuits against public
participation generally lawsuits trying
to stifle free speech and anti-slap laws
are generally a good thing for freedom
of speech they are intended to prevent
people from using courts to intimidate
people who are simply exercising their
free speech rights media groups and
individual journalists can use an
anti-slap statute to protect themselves
from baseless legal threats and
interestingly while former president
trump has been known to file a meritless
lawsuit or two
and had anti-slap laws used against him
former president trump also used an
anti-slap law in his favor to get
attorney's fees back from stormy daniels
when the court ruled that the stormy
daniels lawsuit was meritless and
infringed on former president trump's
right to free speech in this case the
texas anti-slap law the tcpa was
initially criticized for being so broad
that it allowed defenders to dismiss too
many types of cases including attorney
discipline proceedings and employment
law matters where the issue wasn't
really about free speech but in 2019 the
texas legislature narrowed the scope of
the law hoping to confine it to cases
involving the first amendment and the
tcpa now provides litigants like jones
with an early opportunity to move to
dismiss a lawsuit that infringes on his
first amendment rights and if successful
that person can then receive an award of
attorney's fees so jones and infowars
had a right to file a tcpa motion and
they did so for all four of the cases
the trial judge stayed the proceedings
while jones fought for his first
amendment rights and so far there's
nothing improper about any of that jones
has as many first amendment rights as
anyone else and we might not like what
he has to say but that's why the first
amendment exists to protect people and
their right to say what they want to say
but jones has always maintained that he
had a first amendment right to report
about the sandy hook massacre but his
own statements given under oath have
undermined his defense to defamation
jones first got himself into hot water
during his deposition in one of the
other sandy hook cases and during that
deposition lawyers played damning clips
of jones on his tv show where he was
mocking parents pretending to cry and
calling their tears bad acting and then
you've got parents laughing
then they walk over to the camera
in response to the clips jones admitted
under oath that his statements were
false jones said the media traumatized
him because they were all such great big
liars and the big old media therefore
caused jones to suffer from a psychosis
where he simply made things up about
these families and their children as you
can imagine these kinds of admissions
hurt jones in all the defamation cases
filed by the sandy hook families and
made it easier for them to prove
intentional infliction of emotional
distress
jones argued that he had a right to ask
questions and that he relied on evidence
he found online through news reports
quote they staged sandy hook the
evidence is just overwhelming and that's
why i'm so desperate and freaked out
said jones in 2013. and his argument was
that as a news organization he and his
staff had the right to ask questions
speculate and rely on what others were
reporting in formulating their own
opinions in addition to doing their own
reporting and members of the media are
generally allowed to do just that of
course a lot of these claims were
undermined by some damning deposition
testimony and during the litigation of
these motions jones admitted that all
the factual allegations and the
plaintiff's pleadings were true which
isn't really unusual in a defamation
case
often you know what statements are being
made by both parties so
it's not unusual for a defendant to
necessarily
agree with the factual allegations of
the plaintiff's pleadings it's just that
they disagree that they rise to the
level of a defamatory statement and not
surprisingly jones argued that all of
his statements were constitutionally
protected expressions of opinion rather
than statements of fact and under texas
law courts must consider the following
factors in determining whether a
statement is one of opinion or fact one
the statement must be provable as false
at least where public official or public
figure plaintiffs are involved two
constitutional protection is afforded to
statements that cannot reasonably be
interpreted as stating actual facts in
order to assure that the public debate
will not suffer for lack of imaginative
expression or rhetorical hyperbole or
three where the standard of opinion on a
matter of public concern reasonably
implies false and defamatory facts
regarding public figures or officials
those individuals must show that such
statements were made with knowledge of
their false implications or with
reckless disregard for the truth and
four the statements must be given quote
enhanced appellate review to ensure that
these determinations are made in a
manner that does not constitute a
forbidden intrusion into free speech now
a texas appeals court concluded that
statements by jones and his contributors
crossed the line from hyperbole into
reckless and defamatory and once these
defenses were litigated the courts
determined that the fair reporting
privilege didn't prevent the plaintiffs
from suing jones and infowars
so that meant that the civil suits could
go forward and alex jones needed to
respond to the discovery requests and in
july of 2021 the plaintiff's lawyers
offered to give jones and other
defendants 14 more days to answer
discovery and they even agreed to wave
all objections to the lateness of the
discovery responses as long as jones
answered within 14 days but the jones
legal team merely asked for a copy of
the discovery requests which they were
three years old at that point and then
they failed to make any responses
whatsoever that prompted posner's
lawyers to file a motion to compel
discovery and for sanctions in the
heslin case the court ordered jones to
sit for a deposition and to respond to
discovery and that was in october of
2019 jones didn't comply so in december
the court assessed sanctions and held
jones in contempt and that was back at
the time that jones had filed his own
motion to dismiss under the tcpa and the
court stayed all the legal proceedings
while jones appealed that tcpa motion
and jones promised to supplement his
discovery answers as soon as the stay
was lifted if the court didn't dismiss
the case however when the court of
appeals did not dismiss the case he
didn't do so in fact the jones
defendants failed to supplement any
discovery after the stay was lifted and
a similar pattern happened in the lewis
case where the court ordered jones to
respond to discovery way back in
february of 2019. jones was supposed to
have a deposition in march of 2019 but
instead nothing happened in the
proceedings ground to a halt when the
judge assessed sanctions in the lewis
case jones offered up some documents but
each time that happened the documents
were not responsive to the discovery
requests so what happens when you're a
plaintiff's attorney and the defense
just simply refuses to respond to your
discovery requests well under the texas
rules of civil procedure a litigant may
apply for sanctions or an order
compelling discovery when a litigant
refuses to agree to respond to discovery
or refuses to provide answers and
motions to compel discovery and for
sanctions are not rare at all usually if
they're granted they result in the court
actually compelling the party to turn
over discovery or barring the party
resisting discovery from asserting a
certain defense or finding the party and
maybe getting some attorney's fees for
having to go through the fight this
happens all the time because people
don't like giving up information to the
other side but in this case the court
was so exasperated by alex jones's
willful conduct the judge decided to
enter a default judgment instead now a
default judgment is a binding judgment
in favor of the other party based on
some failure to take action by that
party if this occurs a court might rule
in favor of the plaintiff by default now
it's pretty common for judges to enter a
default judgment in cases where a
defendant despite being properly served
simply never enters an appearance or
answers the plaintiff's complaint that's
why if you're sued with a lawsuit you
need to talk to a lawyer because if you
don't respond
you're going to get a default judgment
however here the judge entered the
default judgment because the court
believed that less serious sanctions
would not deter alex jones from similar
actions in the future
the court rejects lesser sanctions
because they've proven ineffective when
previously ordered they would also
benefit defendants and increase the cost
to plaintiff the court held that jones
had shown a consistent pattern of
discovery abuse not only on the three
related cases but in their other
litigation pertaining to sandy hook in
general the court also noted that jones
had failed to answer discovery in a
defamation case involving alex jones's
statements about a school shooting at
marjory stoneman douglas high school in
florida and of course alex jones had a
right to file a motion to dismiss the
lawsuits and he had every right to try
to use the tcpa
it wasn't a crazy argument to think that
the anti-slap laws might apply and give
him a defense but having lost that fight
he had a legal responsibility to obey
the orders of the court and participate
in the discovery process and the lesson
to never piss off the judge is always a
good one the texas court concluded that
given defendant's bad faith approach to
litigation mr jones's public threats in
mr jones's professed belief that the
proceedings are show trials that
entering a series of escalating
consequences would be useless so the
court entered a default judgment against
alex jones the court opted not to issue
sanctions against his lawyers noting
that jones had seven lawyers during the
course of this litigation that basically
alex jones did whatever he wanted
regardless of who was representing him
so congratulations alex jones you played
yourself and that's not all now alex
jones has lost all 10 lawsuits brought
by families of people killed in the
sandy hook massacre in november a
connecticut state court ruled that
because jones disregarded orders
requiring him to turn over documents
he's liable by default the connecticut
judge used the same logic as the texas
court the lead plaintiff in the
connecticut case is erica lafferty the
daughter of the school principal dawn
lafferty hofspuring who was murdered by
the same gunman as the sandy hook
children the other plaintiffs include
william aldenberg a first responder who
jones is labeled a crisis actor and when
there's a default judgment that doesn't
mean the case is over there still has to
be a trial on the matter of damages this
is generally called a prove up where the
winner of the trial has to demonstrate
the actual damages that they suffered
though liability is no longer contested
because you know that was the the
penalty so now both state courts will
now schedule a trial on how much jones
has to pay
jones has already vowed to appeal the
connecticut rulings and he also claimed
that the state courts were conspiring
against him to deny him due process
quote these individuals again are not
allowing me to have a jury trial because
they know the things they said i
supposedly did didn't happen and they
know they didn't have a case for damages
so the lesson is if you get sued you
should actually participate in the legal
process and not obstruct like alex jones
and if you do get sued call your lawyer
immediately and when you make that call
you can save a ton of money on your cell
phone bill with today's sponsor ting
mobile in fact i personally switched to
st mobile and saved literally hundreds
of dollars a month i'm not kidding why
well because of this yes this is a real
cell phone bill that i got with my
previous provider and it's why i
personally switched to ting in fact ting
was recently ranked the number one
carrier in america by consumer reports
and ting mobile has three brand new
plans to make sure that happens again
and all of team's plans have unlimited
talk and text starting at just 10 per
month so you can use the flex plan and
only pay for what you use which is
especially great if you're around wi-fi
all day you can choose a set of 12
gigabytes of data for just 35 or get
full unlimited for
dollars a month switching plans is
actually really easy because you can
keep your same phone number and use
pretty much any phone and the service is
great too because ting partners with
several massive networks probably the
very same one you're using right now but
at a huge discount they literally use
the same infrastructure now actually i
can't tell you which ones because i
always respect contracts but let's just
say my service hasn't changed at all and
when you're around wi-fi all the time
like you're working from home you have
the flexibility to save hundreds of
dollars a year and ting still gives you
the option to just pay for what you use
with their flex plan now they just give
you the possibility of unlimited
versions as well so if you want
unlimited you can go absolutely crazy
and it's incredibly easy to transfer
service because you just order a ting
sim card pop it in and set it up no
phone call required it's like magic but
if you do want to talk to ting you can
call them up and immediately talk to a
real human being or chat with them on
discord or on instant message you will
talk to real humans not ai robots
virtually no wait times so if you'd like
to give ting a try legal eagles will get
a 325 service credit that could cover
two months of service all you have to do
is click on the link below or the link
that's on screen right now you can even
use your last bill to compare just how
much you would save so click on the link
that's on screen or in the description
plus clicking on those links really
helps out this channel and while you're
there check out this playlist over here
with all my other real law reviews on
the most important legal issues of the
day so click on this playlist or i'll
see you in court